Davos Seaworth: What's this one now?
Shireen Baratheon: "The Dance of Dragons,
A True Telling" by Grand Maester Munkun.
Davos: Now that sounds like a proper story.
Stannis Baratheon: What's it about?
Shireen: It's the story of the fight between
Rhaenyra Targaryen and her half-brother Aegon
for control of the Seven Kingdoms.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne.
When people started declaring for one of them
or the other, their fight divided the kingdoms
in two.
Brothers fought brothers, dragons fought dragons.
By the time it was over, thousands were dead.
And it was a disaster for the Targaryens as
well.
They never truly recovered.
Stannis: The Dance of Dragons.
Why is that a dance?
Shireen: It's just what they call it.
Stannis: Hmm.
Doesn't make much sense.
Shireen: I think it's poetic.
Joffrey Baratheon: Rhaenyra Targaryen was
murdered by her brother, or rather, his dragon.
It ate her while her son watched.
Stannis: If you'd had to choose between Rhaenyra
and Aegon, who would you have chosen?
Shireen: I wouldn't have chosen either.
It's all the choosing sides that made everything
so horrible.
Stannis: Sometimes a person has to choose.
Viserys Targaryen:The Dance began, as many
dances do, with an old man and a young girl.
The queen had failed to produce a son for
her king, so he anointed his daughter, the
Princess Rhaenyra, as his heir.
But years later, the king remarried, and his
new wife, Queen Alicent of House Hightower,
gave him a son.
Feeble and foolish, the old king refused to
change the succession.
He didn't even see how his court had split
into two rival camps of Blacks and Greens,
after the dresses that the princess and the
queen had worn to some tourney.
One night, a servant found the old king had
died in his sleep and ran to inform Queen
Alicent.
Protocol dictated that the bells would be
rung and a ravensent to Dragonstone to summon
the heir, Princess Rhaenyra, for her coronation.
But Alicent had other plans.
Lord Commander of the Kingsguard, Ser Criston
Cole, summoned the small council to inform
them of the king's death.
Ser Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King and
father to Queen Alicent, demanded that the
succession be settled immediately.
The decrepit old men of the small council
were confused; the succession was settled
in their minds.
The old king had forced the lords of Westeros
to swear fealty to Princess Rhaenyra as his
heir.
But SerCriston Cole rightly pointed out that
a son comes before a daughter.
The council argued until dawn when the Master
of Coin finally stood up and declared he would
have no part of treason.
SerCriston Cole wisely opened his throat with
a dagger, ending the debate.
None were more surprised to hear of Prince
Aegon's succession than Prince Aegon himself.
At first, the fool rejected the crown, but
his mother pointed out that his sister Rhaenyra
would return such loyalty by taking his head.
When ravens carried the news of Aegon's coronation
to Dragonstone, Princess Rhaenyra summoned
her own Black Council.
With her was her uncle and husband, Daemon
Targaryen, considered by many to be the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
Few lords supported her, but the greatest
of these was CorlysVelaryon, who controlled
the largest fleet in the realm, and his Targaryen
wife Rhaenys, the old king's sister.
Then there were her five sons, although none
grown to manhood.
A pitiful assembly, really.
Combined they couldn't match the power of
House Hightower alone.
But Rhaenyra had dragons.
She, Daemon, and Rhaenys rode huge and formidable
beasts, and three of her five sons were riders
as well.
Dragonstone also housed six more dragons without
riders.
Against this, King Aegon had only four dragons
of his own.
Dragons can burn a city, but only armies can
take and hold it.
If she was to prevail, Rhaenyra desperately
needed the support of the few great houses
not already sworn to Aegon.
Her eldest son, Jacaerys, flew to the Vale
and the North, her middle son Lucerys flew
to the Stormlands.
Rhaenyra hoped that the war would begin and,
if the gods were good, end with diplomacy.
As always, they weren't.
Robert Baratheon:Go home, pup, and tell the mother, that the Lord of Storm's
End is not a dog she can whistle on.
As Aemond's false eyed gleamed at him, the
princeling fled the castle and mounted his
young dragon Arrax.
The rain fell in sheets, and great bolts of
lightning lit the world bright as day.
Arrax was struggling to stay aloft in the
gale when a roar shook the very foundations
of Storm's End.
Aemond rose through the clouds and below him
the monstrous Vhagar.
Prince Lucerys fell, broken, to be swallowed
by the waves.
With his death, the war of ravens came to
an end, and the war of fire and blood began.
Catelyn Stark: When Rhaenyra heard of her
son's death, she collapsed.
She considered ending the war right then until
a raven arrived from her husband, Daemon.
Her son would be avenged.
A son for a son.
Viserys:Rhaenyra shipped her two youngest
sons across the Narrow Sea for their protection.
Only for her youngest to return days later,
clinging to the neck of his wounded and dying
dragon.
He and his brother had been set upon by an
enemy fleet just off Dragonstone.
Defying his mother's command, Rhaenyra's eldest
son and heir, Jacaerys, mounted his dragon
Vermaxand flew to rescue his other brother
and punish the enemy fleet.
But the foolish boy let Vermax be hooked like
a trout and dragged into the sea, where he
soaked up even more arrows than seawater.
His brother disappeared over the horizon or
beneath the waves.
No one could say for sure.
With the loss of four dragons, Rhaenyra's
only advantage was fading.
Luckily for her, over the centuries, House
Targaryen had spilled more than blood on Dragonstone.
She promised gold and title to any of the
Targaryen bastards who could tame the six
untamed dragons on the island.
These bastards were called the dragonseeds,
though most were called supper.
Perhaps the dragons were eventually sated
or bored, but four of them accepted riders
and were enlisted in Rhaenyra's cause.
Robert:King's Landing looked up and saw two
dragons circling their foul city.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had come for her throne,
for the city was defenseless.
Aemond had taken the king's army from the
city, and worse, he'd taken his dragon Vhagar.
Seeing that resistance was hopeless, the small
council surrendered the city, the Queen Mother
Alicent, and the broken Queen Helaena.
But not King Aegon.
Somehow, despite his wounds and delirium,
he had vanished from the city.
And so Queen Rhaenyra climbed the steps and
seated herself of the Iron Throne.
Legend has it that as she left that hall later,
blood trickled down her legs and hands, proving
the Iron Throne had spurned her.
Nonsense!
It's a chair made of steel blades.
Rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and had
sacrificed two sons for it.
She likely gripped the damn thing too tight.
Viserys:Queen Rhaenyra didn't have much time
to grieve for her stupid husband.
The mad former queen Helaena flung herself
from a balcony, to be impaled upon the iron
spikes lining the moat of Maegor's Holdfast.
That night, the city rose in riot against
Rhaenyra, demanding justice for Queen Helaena
and her murdered son, among other foolish
peasantfantasies.
In the midst of this chaos, a one-handed fool
called the Shepherd began to rant against
dragons.
Not just the ones of the enemy, but all dragons
everywhere.
As he pointed to the Dragonpit above on the
hill, he shouted, "There the demons dwell,
this is their city.
If you would make it yours, first you must
destroy them."
By the time the first of the attackers came
pouring in, all four were roused, awake and
angry.
Nobody knows how many men and women died that
night.
Who cares?
They all should have!
Trapped within the pit, the dragons could
not fly.
Instead, they fought with horns, claws, teeth,
and fire.
For every man who died, ten more appeared,
shouting that the dragons must die.
One by one, they did.
Finally, the last remaining dragon broke her
chain, spread her wings, and flew straight
up at the great dome trying to flee.
Already weakened by dragonflame, the dome
cracked under the force of impact and then
tumbled down, crushing the dragonslayers and
herself.
Joffrey Baratheon: High atop the Red Keep,
Queen Rhaenyra clutched her two remaining
sons to her as she watched the end of her
family's might, too afraid of the peasants
to defend her dragons.
At least her older son, Joffrey, had a man's
spine.
He stole his mother's dragon Syrax and tried
to fly it to the Dragonpit to save his birthright.
But the stupid beast didn't understand and
twisted beneath him, fighting to be free of
the little boy, until it was.
Weeping for her lost son more than her dragons,
Rhaenyra abandoned the Iron Throne and sold
her crown to buy passage for her and her last
son back to Dragonstone.
Rhaenyra hoped to hatch more dragons from
the eggs in the castle.
But when she landed, the welcoming party slew
her guards and marched her and her son at
spearpoint to the castle to face a dead man
and a dying dragon.
"Sister!"
King Aegon, Second of His Name, called out
to Rhaenyra.
Rook's Rest had left Aegon bent and twisted,
his once handsome face puffy from milk of
the poppy, with burn scars covering half his
body.
Rhaenyra, ever defiant, told her dear brother
that she'd hoped he was dead.
"After you!"
Aegon answered.
Then Sunfyre bathed her in a blast of flame
and devoured her in six bites while her son
watched, leaving the seventh and final bite,
her lower leg, for the Stranger.